hello everyone and welcome to an
incredible game that just finished from
round eight of this year's Tata still
Masters it is ala fuja versus world
champion ding Len and both of them are
having an interesting event to say the
least alza already lost two games um the
one women's world champion ju and
Gujarati but he also won a lot of games
and ding having a pretty pretty uh you
know uh neutralist tournament he's
currently on 50% and he did lose that
one to prar so both of them would of
course love a victory here and as ala
fua is one of the candidates of the 2024
candidates tournament and the ding is
the world champion uh we could also be
looking at a the potential matchup for a
World Chess Championship match but we'll
see how it goes so let's check it out
I'm sure you guys already know what
happened as it's a very short game uh
let's dive straight into it so Al Isa
with the white pieces opens with D4 we
have Knight to C6 Knight to F6 C4 we
have E6 Knight F3 and pawn to D5 uh the
Queen's gamb declined is on the board we
have Knight to C3 uh and now Pawn to C5
again this three Knight system of the uh
of the setup and now the youup of
Rubenstein system with Pawn to E3 uh we
have Knight to C6 a fairly uh rare move
usually you just capture in the center
but okay Knight to C6 we have A3 and D
captures on C4 uh so transposing into
the symmetrical tarash we have Bishop
captures on C4 and now Pawn to A6 and
here uh castles is the absolute top move
here pretty much everyone plays it and
there are some games where D captures
and C5 is played uh but here ala goes
back Bishop to A2 and it's not a new
move but it's incredibly rare only one
game where the move was played H we have
Pawn to B5 by Ding and now Queen to C2
in that game that I mentioned castles
was played but here we have Queen to C2
and already as of move nine we have a
completely new game
so what is ala's idea with this early
Bishop to A2 move well okay let's see C
captures and D4 bying with have e
captures and Bishop to B7 nicely fing
the light Square bishop and now Pawn to
D5 ala just sacrifices a pawn for for
what reason uh well let's see e captures
on D5 ding captures it and you should it
is um best to capture it right away uh
and now as in the previous game first
ala makes some sort of a sacrifice and
then he starts thinking so this is the
first real think of the game and Al Isa
spend some 20 minutes pondering on
Bishop to G5 which he did play uh and
here deing just replied Bishop to E7
doesn't look like all that much we have
Rook to D1 by Ala now putting more
pressure on this D5 uh D5 Pawn uh with
the bishop here attacking one of the
Defenders and ding just advances it we
have Pawn to D4 uh or you could uh you
know have it stay on D5 as a Target but
ding feels comfortable advancing it to
D4 and it is still perfectly fine uh we
have Castles by Ala of course the Knight
cannot be captured the queen would hang
and now Castles by Ding and here just
Rook F to E1 and for the price of that
one Pawn uh ding uh well ala has now uh
developed all of his pieces and the ding
after some 25 minute thing uh goes Pawn
to B4 and it is very strong it puts
pressure on the Knight now you have to
decide what to do here and you could
just move it back Knight D2 you go after
the D4 pawn and it's perfectly fine but
ala goes Bishop to B1 just puts pressure
on the H7 pawn and yes he's defended by
the Knight but you can easily capture it
idea is that if it captures on C3 you're
going to capture on F6 uh then G6 has to
be played in order to avoid Checkmate
and after let's say Bishop captures an
E7 and Knight captures you will win back
your D4 Pawn with an attack on the queen
and once the queen moves you will also
pick up the uh the C3 pawn and you're
just going to be up a pawn and okay
Queens get traded off captures captures
and the problem is if you um capture on
F3 let's say Bishop captures you will
see Rook captures on E7 of course um not
doubling the pawns and now after Rook F
d8 idea being that if if you trade and
pick up the bishop then there's this
Rook to E1 check picking up the bishop
on B1 so Rook to E3 will be played and
something like Bishop to C6 and this is
the position you would get ala would be
up upon PA it's a it's a forcing line so
this is exactly what we would see so of
course ding doesn't go for that he plays
Pawn to G6 just stops Checkmate and um
has this threat of B captures and C3 so
d uh ala goes Rook captures on E7 and
now uh what can you play here well you
can't waste time with B captures on C3
now as the bishop on B7 is hanging as
well so The Rook must be captured we
have Knight captures on E7 not Queen
captures on E7 if you play Queen
captures looks nice as it moves the
queen away from the dile but then
there's Knight D5 attacks the queen and
the Knight here and after well there's
no after you you move the queen and you
lose the Knight or you give up your
queen and uh well it's just not enough
compensation it's going to be a knight
and a rook for the White Queen of course
this is completely winning for white so
instead after Rook captures on E7 Knight
captures on E7 is played and now comes
Rook captures on D4 attacking dink's
Queen uh on d8 and now what would you
play here it's uh your queen is hanging
uh your knight is hanging is there is
there a way to solve your your problems
here uh well uh ding played the queen to
C7 point being that okay the Knight is
hanging but also this knight uh is
hanging so it's not it's not a big deal
but this is the move that loses the game
for ding the real move after Rook
captures on D4 was this Knight E to D5
move and it looks very silly you know
now the queen this Knight is pinned the
queen is behind the the bishop also this
Knight is pinned you have to you know a
double self pin if you will
and then after Knight to E4 going after
the Knight you just move the queen unpin
from the D file and you sort of control
everything if a captures on B4 then you
can play Rook a to C8 attack the queen
and once the queen moves you're going to
go Rook F to d8 and you you know develop
everything the game continues nothing
really happening here however ding
played this queen to C7 move and he
didn't really use that much time he
spent like five minutes um on this
position uh but now his position is dead
lost and I'm pretty sure you guys see it
but just in case feel free to pause the
video and take down the reigning world
champion while I give you a couple of
seconds so uh for those of you who were
able to do it congratulations on
realizing that uh well the the the the
check does does exist in chess and for
those of you who just want to enjoy the
show it is Knight to E4 and this opens
up an attack on the black queen which is
undefended and also on the Knight on F6
which is undefended and the problem is
uh well you can't trade Queens but it's
uh kind of your your only option because
if you go let's say you go Knight F to
D5 you want to defend your queen it's
not really defended you're going to
capture it and after Knight captures
this leaves the Knight on E7 undefended
and now you're just um uh up too much
material uh and the other move that you
might think is let's play Knight
captures on e4 can we give up the queen
this way well not really if Queen
captures and you play Knight captur on
G5 uh literally any move for white WIS
you can also just recapture and again
you're just up too much material black
has zero compensation here so after
Knight E4 Queen captures and C2 was
played ding has to go into this end game
being down a piece and okay Al Isa takes
it Knight captures on F6 with check King
G7 and Bishop captures on C2 and okay
ala did sacrifice The Exchange uh so if
you count the pieces now there's a rook
on each side a knight on each side and a
bishop on each side and alza will have a
bishop and Knight for a rook on A8 and
that's that's a lot of material so okay
Rook 8 to C8 going after the bishop on
C2 but ala uh isn't tricked by this
attack on the bishop he just plays
Knight to G4 and uh it's also uh you
know very useful that uh if Rook
captures on C2 is played you of course
don't go after the Knight on E7 you just
checkmated the black king Bishop to F6
check the king cannot go to H6 King and
Knight to H6 will be Checkmate that's
why Knight to G4 is so so strong so
Knight to G8 is played and now just
Bishop to B3 you don't have to worry
about the back rank the bishop here is
covering the C1 Square so B captures on
A3 B captures now Rook the C3 and of
course Rook to B4 putting pressure on
the bishop and inviting ding to capture
on F3 it looks great you will win back
some material uh but um uh of course ala
does this with with another trick up his
leave a ding goes for Bishop captures on
F3 G captures Rook captures and now just
Knight to E3 trapping ding's Rook on F3
this covered by the bishop by the bishop
this covered by the Knight King G2 will
just win The Rook uh or well win the
exchange ding will of course capture
something so it's not that Ding would
fall for this if it was a regular
possession but he knows he's already
lost and he's just trying to reach move
40 uh so someone you know doesn't Post
online that Ding lost in a miniature to
Ala you know uh avoid all the all the
quick news so here Pawn to H6 attacks
the bishop we have Bishop back to uh
sorry Bishop back to D1 attacking The
Rook on F3 and now just Rook captures on
F2 saying okay uh you win my Rook I will
take your Bishop but at least I will win
a pawn while I'm at it but ala say nope
no you won't Bishop captures on H6 he
also grabs a pawn with Tempo and only
then will he capture The Rook so okay
Knight captures on H6 King captures on
F2 and now Rook to d8 and now this is of
course completely unplayable for black
but ding will try uh at least to reach
move 40 ala has 13 minutes on the clock
so maybe you know 10 moves uh for 13
minutes maybe he messes it up uh we have
Rook to D6 and now Bishop to B3 of
course um very hard for ala to M this up
he will just now go after the a pawn
that cannot be stop it and then you just
Advance your past a point to Victory
that's one way to do it but in this
position there are many ways to do it so
Rook to F6 is played uh Pawn to A4
advancing the pawn as far as possible
before capturing on A6 uh Rook to C6 and
now just Bishop to C4 we have Pawn to F5
ding will also try to create some sort
of a pass Pawn uh gam play now Rook to
B7 with check King to F6 and now even
Rook to H7 ala being engine like U
precise here just going after the Knight
here the bishop covers the light squares
and the Knight has to be traded off so
Knight to G4 Alla happily trades we have
captures captures and now just Bishop
back to D3 going now after the G6 Pawn
so Rook to B6 and now Rook to A7 not
going after G6 but after the A6 Pawn
Rook to B2 check we have King to E3 and
Rook captures on H2 so ding does create
the pass G Pawn but ala also creates a
pass a pawn with check we have King to
E5 now comes Rook A5 check King to F6
and now King to f four and he was in
this position un move 43 that world
champion ding Len resigned the game as
there is nothing more to be done here uh
of course you you are down a full piece
and there's no there's no counterplay
here you cannot Advance the pawn you
cannot defend the pawn
uh what whatever white plays is
completely winning here it would be
pointless to continue and since we've
already reach time Controla will not be
having any time problems there's no
reason for ding to continue the game uh
so yeah a tough break for world champion
ding Len losing another game uh but yeah
okay he has been absent from classical
chess for a very long time for over a
year and it will take time for him to to
get back into it uh but hopefully he
will be ready to uh to play some serious
chess when it's time to defend His World
Chess Championship title and yeah great
uh great uh victory for ala who takes
down a world champion in classical chess
that's something not everyone you know
can just add to theed res but ala does
so so brilliant stuff and with this
Victory I think ala joins the leaders
yeah for the moment as all the other
games are still being played only one
game ended in a draw ala does join Anish
giri in the lead but probably some other
players will also join them after uh
after the round is over uh so uh what
are you going to do that's how chess
Works uh one day you give your opponent
a less and the next day he gives you one
as good friend Bobby Fisher said so this
day ala was the one giving the lesson uh
so I would like to thank Johan Glens Len
Herbert yunong an anonymous person in
Christopher and Ruth Beret for your
contribution to my channel thank you a
lot to really appreciate it as usual you
can check two of my previous videos here
thank you all for watching and I will
see you soon continuing to check up on
your wonderful suggestions but mostly
covering the Tata steel uh until it
finishes uh so thank you all I will see
you soon and have an excellent rest of
your day